give you a snapshot of where the cases
are coming from but we need more
specific information to have a specific
battle plan literally where do the new
cases come from
are they essential workers are they
people who are staying home and getting
infected by a family member or they
essential workers who are still
traveling and possibly getting infected
at work where do they work how do they
commute is this a question of getting
infected on public transportation we
just announced new subway buses Long
Island Railroad Metro North protocols
where in the state are these people who
are being transferred from a nursing
home what's their sex what's their age
what's their previous health status what
are the demographics let's get more
specific information from the hospitals
to see if we can come up with a strategy
that is more tailored through the
reduction of these 1,000 cases per day
the number of deaths 289 lower than it
has been but still tragic and terrible
and all the good numbers or the good
news for me every day this number just
wipes that all away we announced a
statewide policy for our schools we did
it last March 18th we said that we were
going to close schools all across the
state k12 and higher education schools
we waved what was called the 180 day
requirement which was the state
regulation that schools had to have 180
days of teaching schools then
transferred to distance learning
programs meal delivery services
childcare options for essential workers
that has actually worked out well not
perfectly we had to do it in a rush but
there are lessons that we can learn here
that could change teaching going forward
and teaching in these types of
situations going
for word but it did work basically
functioned well and teachers did a
phenomenal job stepping up to do this it
was a hardship on everyone but we made
the best of the situation
colleges and universities were also
moved to distance learning campuses were
closed unless the student really needed
housing on the campus schools obviously
by definition have higher density they
have transportation issues kids who are
getting on a bus we didn't have the
protective measures to put in place you
have 700 public school districts 4800
schools in this state then you have
1,800 private schools 89 SUNY and CUNY
campuses 100 private colleges and total
is 4.2 million students so the decisions
on the education system are obviously
critically important we must protect our
children every parent every citizen
feels that we must protect our students
we have to protect our educators and
given the circumstances that we're in
and the precautions that would have to
be put in place to come up with a plan
to reopen schools with all those new
protocols how do you an operate a school
that's socially distanced with masks
without gatherings with a public
transportation system that has a lower
number of students on it how would you
get that plan up and running we don't
think it's possible to do that in a way
that would keep our children and
students and educators safe so we're
going to have the schools remain closed
for the rest of the year we're going to
continue the distance learning programs
schools have asked about summer school
and whether we'll have attendance in
schools for summer school that decision
will be made by the end of this month
again nobody can predict what the
situation is going to be three four
weeks from now
so we're trying to stage decisions at
intervals that give us the information
but also enough time for people to make
the preparations they need to make so
any decisions on summer schools will be
made by the end of this month but in the
meantime meal programs will continue the
childcare services where essential
workers will continue and then we want
schools to start now developing a plan
to reopen and the plan has to have
protocols in place that incorporate
everything that we are now doing in
society and everything that we learn
we're going to be asking businesses to
come up with plans that safeguard
workers when they reopen we need schools
to come up with plans also that bring
those precautions into the school room
and that's for schools that's also for
colleges and the state will approve
those plans related issue that we need
to discuss and we need to pay attention
to this Colvard crisis has caused
significant disruption and many
unintended consequences and ancillary
issues that have developed and one of
them is when you have people who are put
in this situation immediately with no
notice it has caused serious mental
health issues you have anxiety
depression insomnia loneliness that
feeling of isolation we're seeing the
use of drugs go up we're seeing the use
of alcohol consumption go up this is a
chronic problem if you're feeling these
issues you're not alone as a matter of
fact half of all Americans have said
that their mental health has been
negatively impacted don't underestimate
the stress of this situation and it
happened
on a lot of levels three out of four say
that their sleep has been affected you
don't know where that your next paycheck
is coming from you don't know if your
job is going to exist you're at work one
day the next day they say everything is
closed stay in the house you're in that
house in a confined situation or you're
in an apartment in a confined situation
you can't get out it's difficult for
emotional support we have a hotline that
is set up people shouldn't be shy in any
way or have any second thoughts about
calling for help
it is a pervasive problem and people
should make the call and get the help if
they need the help we also see in line
with what we're talking about a dramatic
increase in the incidence of domestic
violence there was a 15 percent increase
in March a 30% increase in April that's
March is when they started 15 percent
April 30 percent that is a frightening
rate and level of increase again New
Yorkers in need we have a domestic
violence helpline 844 997 2121 you can
call just discuss the issue you don't
have to give your identity you don't
have to say where you live but people
who need help should reach out there was
no shame in reaching out and saying I
need help this is a national epidemic
it's a statewide epidemic ask for help
and we're here to help we're especially
concerned about these issues for
frontline workers I mean just think
about what the frontline workers are
going through think about what the
health care workers are going through
they're working extended hours they're
seeing a large number of people die
they're working in very frightening
situations they're worried about their
own health they're worried they get
infected they then have to go
worried if they're infected are they
bringing that infection home so this is
a terribly stressful difficult time
especially for the frontline workers and
we want them to know that we not only
appreciate what they're doing but we're
there to support them right saying thank
you is nice acting in gratitude is even
nicer so we have a special emotional
support hotline for our central workers
and we're also going to direct all
insurers to waive any cost-sharing
co-pays deductibles for mental health
services for essential workers which
means the mental health services will be
free for frontline workers and there'll
be at no cost and too many people too
many families have said to me well you
know I would go for services but I don't
want to pay the cost I can't afford it I
don't want to take that money for my
family that's gone there is no cost to
get mental health services so just wipe
that reason away and get the help that
you need it's even on if it's even in
the best interest of your family a last
point personal opinion who said when
life knocks you on your ear learn grow
up and get back up was that Ajay
Parkinson who was not Ajay Parkinson it
was me nobody ever said that just me
when life knocks you on your rear
thought that that learn grow and get
back up this has been a very difficult
difficult situation for everyone but
when life knocks you on your rear learn
and grow and we will collectively learn
and grow where we're gonna learn many
difficult lessons from this situation
we're going to learn about public health
threats that we never saw before we
never heard of we never really
anticipated we never actualized everyone
talked about global pandemics and that
possibility but you know what until it
happens people don't really get it our
hospital system and how that works and
how it works in an emergency hotel
education works out telemedicine works
how you keep society functioning during
an emergency how you communicate to
people the dangers of a situation
without panicking people because you
still need essential workers to come out
and do their job you don't want to panic
people where they say I'm not leaving
the house but you need to communicate
the facts so people act responsibly how
do you do that in a short period of time
what do you do about public
transportation you learn the whole
lesson with the downstate public
transportation system so there'll be a
lot to learn from this which we will
learn and we will be the better for I
believe that and that's that's part of
life in the meantime we have to go day
to day and we try to make the best of a
bad situation you try to find that
silver lining through the dark clouds
all of us try to do it in our own way
everybody is struggling with it in their
own way and that's all across the board
in many ways this is the great equalizer
it doesn't doesn't matter who you are
where you are this impacts your life
dramatically but personally if you work
at it maybe you can find a little silver
lining I'm sitting there last night with
my daughter Mikayla she's my baby the
baby is now 22 and she says to me you
know that think about it I've spent more
time with you now then I will probably
spend with you in the rest of my adult
life
I said Wow what does that mean
she said well think about it I've been
with you for over a month I won't be
with you for another month for the rest
of my adult life which is kind of
jarring cuz I still think of her as my
baby but you know what that's probably
right
you know she's 22 she's gonna go off to
whatever she does and then you see her
at holidays for a few hours here maybe
you steal a Saturday once in a while
reminded me of the Harry Chapin song
cat's in the cradle which was a great
old song from a great great man great
New Yorker too but these are with all
the bizarreness I haven't been able to
see my mother in two months but I have
my daughter probably for a longer period
of time
then I probably have for the rest of her
adult life that's probably true so you
try to find the silver lining you try to
stay positive we stay socially distance
but we stay spiritually connected New
Yorkers have been so supportive of each
other you can feel it there's a spirit
of community and mutuality people are
there to help one another people
understand that everybody is going
through this everybody's in stress you
look at the way people have complied
with these rules as annoying as they are
masks six feet this that's out of
respect one for the other
I love the metaphor of the mask the mask
does not protect me I wear the mask to
protect you what a beautiful sign of
caring of mutuality I wear a mask to
protect you that's that's the spirit
even in this terrible time of difficulty
so yes you can be socially distance but
you can be spiritually connected and
closer in ways you've never been before
and I believe that's where we are
because we are New York tough which
means tough smart United disciplined and
loving questions States start to Rio
could school start to reopen as early as
its fall possibly sooner and we're
hearing that New York City their
teachers are looking at remote learning
possibly in the fall so I just learned
about the timeline of all this and what
could happen at the earliest there will
be no opening of any school in the state
for the remainder of the academic
calendar year we have to decide on
summer school that decision will be made
by the end of May there is no decision
on the fall because the fall is a long
time wait that depends when they're
going to open but they should start
preparing their plans now because this
is going to be a real exercise you know
we're talking about how manufacturing
companies socially distance how
construction companies socially distance
how does this school socially distance
you know this bizarre set up here right
look at this room how do you run a
school like this
how many more rooms would you need to do
this how many more buses do you need to
socially distance on a bus you know
there's a whole how about a cafeteria
there's a whole set of questions how
about a dorm room so they should start
working on those plans now
teachers can realistically do this in
school administrators I mean kids are
kids they're gonna want to run around
and be together as well if that that is
a very good question Karen and that's
what we you know talking to people all
across the state educators all across
the state you can come up with a plan
which is by the way very hard right they
talk about spatial requirements if you
did this if you require this in a
classroom how many more classrooms would
you need in a building right but then
there's the other question of K to 12
and then how do I get students not to
socially distance you know how do you
tell a ten-year-old though it's socially
distance so we're gonna err on the side
of caution now that's for the rest of
the school year summer school you would
need to see in my opinion a drop in the
or stabilization of the infection rate
for a period of time because kids are
going to be kids I think you're right
well you couldn't get to more classrooms
anyway right you couldn't build more
classrooms in a way that would have any
difference for summer school or for the
Fall
and money is going to be tight depending
on what Washington does and they're
doing remote learning you know the
fiscal consequences are going to be
mixed because of this period some ways
they save money some ways it costs money
[Applause]
sorry to harp on this but do you do you
anticipate a decision on on pause this
week again in terms of businesses May
15th is the decision on post so you put
what you announced it prior to that or
we'll announce it prior to May 15th and
also just tough just to follow up it's
been two months since the first case was
reported you spoke today of what we
have accomplished and yet there's 18,000
people dead at least over 300,000 people
sick how would you evaluate your
performance during this crisis tried my
best
well we're aware of what New Jersey's
doing with Connecticut's doing we're
trying to coordinate with those states
I've said from day one the you will not
have uniform policies across all the
states but knowing what other states are
going to do because the state can have a
significant effect on a neighboring
state knowing what they do is helpful
and then at the appropriate time we'll
make those decisions the decisions
around summer activities are very
difficult you want to look at the
tension you want to get people out of
their homes give them something to do
but you want to keep the infection rate
down you have these mental health issues
you have domestic violence issues you
have a lot going on so you do want a
relief valve right it's going to get hot
in the summer hopefully and you want to
have a level of activity you don't want
to overwhelm a neighboring state by
keeping everything closed but you don't
want to have high density and violation
of social distancing so that's that's
what we're trying to work through for
the summer activities we have a little
more time and we're talking about that
now just Jessie to go back just go just
even go back to your question for a
second I can tell you this
New Yorkers did an extraordinary job and
reduced the rate of hospitalizations by
about a hundred thousand and saved
thousands of lives so kudos to New
Yorkers
they count around 100 suspected
coronavirus deaths but the state only
had around 13 on hand they had bodies
outside and storage containers is there
gonna be an investigation into that it's
about a geriatric center and is there a
way that there can be more investigation
into some of these chrome virus
suspected deaths well we have the joint
effort between the Attorney General and
the Department of Health that is going
to investigate systemically how nursing
homes handle this situation
and specifically individual problem
areas that we've seen in nursing homes
so that will certainly be part of the
Attorney General and the Department of
Health investigation we have 613 nursing
homes we investigate anything that comes
up if there's a concern we will go in
there find out report back I guess
uniform way of reporting these vests
there is a for mother and saying your
question there is a formal process of
how we go in to investigate try to find
out what happened what were the events
what could we do to prevent that in the
future and we address you all of them
and whether it's tied to a hospital tied
to the nursing home or both just show
you clear on the facts now what we're
doing you we report Hospital deaths and
nursing home deaths separately that's on
the slide every day the question we're
now asking the hospital's one of the
questions that I posed was someone
transferred from a nursing home to a
hospital and then passed away in the
hospital and we want to know that that's
that's your question and that is a good
question and we're going to be asking
that today and when I get on the phone
with the hospitals I'm going to ask them
just that
protecting essential workers you're
disinfecting subway cars and buses in
New York City we're hearing from
essential workers in grocery stores who
tell us they're overwhelmed by people
who are rushing to the store who are not
wearing masks who are not practicing
social distancing and so I guess the
question is should these stores be
refusing to allow customers in who are
not wearing masks and if those essential
employees is showing up for work can
make me denied I don't know maybe it's a
legal question I don't know maybe
Melissa or Rob would know or we can
check look on the grocery stores if I'm
a private grocery store owner and we
have these social distancing
requirements in place and masks in place
I think unless the lawyers want to argue
with me if I'm a private grocery store
owner I would deny admission to a person
who is not wearing a mask you could
endanger my other patrons you could
endanger my employees I would do that I
don't know about this behavior inside a
store you know but I think the private
grocery store owner would be in their
rights summer-school
they will do remote learning they have
to continue to do meals etc we're
talking about summer school attendance
in the building explain the discrepancy
between the nursing home reported deaths
because as a follow-up to Morgan's
question that specific spot there's only
13 reported deaths from her sick from
that nursing home on the Cova tracker
however we've got a report that they had
26 446 deaths
specific to co-ed and then potentially
more in the 50s so what's what's the
explanation for that just
I can see and what are the consequences
what's the name of this nursing home
birth it's called the Isabella geriatric
Center it's in Manhattan does anyone
know we asked we went back and asked the
nursing homes to provide more detailed
data what they were doing in some cases
and not others confirmed plus
unconformity was go back and say what
we're confirmed and what we run
confirmed so sometimes an odd number is
higher because those are actually
unconfirmed cases that they put into
certain reporting we ask them before
they confirmed at first but to get at
this sense of what you're talking about
which is why is the number a little
higher we asked them do you also include
unconfirmed numbers in that as well and
what we're finding is they were in also
including unconfirmed so what we're
doing is putting together a data set
right now that has it by confirmed by a
nursing home and unconfirmed like we
were doing with the others too but that
takes a little time to tease out from
the nursing homes this is something
directly funded almost fifty deaths that
are being reported that's a very large
number are there consequences in case
nursing homes for not reporting the
accurate numbers and what are those
Commissioner as Jim mentioned there's
two parts of this but this is the
evolving situation of the day that's
coming in and we do track this if
there's a concern about specific nursing
home and what the numbers are we will
look into that as well to attest to the
fact that the numbers are true and
accurate and every report they submit to
us if the Commission at the Department
of Health finds that there was
intentional misleading or whatever they
can revoke their license they can find
them penalties under the public health
law they will send people and I think
under this specific instance the
department will go in and investigate
this to see like we've done with others
as well sometimes as the governor and
others have said before this was an
emerging situation there were mistakes
made on reporting some people reported
deaths from December that's a mistake
other cases they were if there's
potential intentional misleading the
Department of Health will investigate
those and then do the appropriate
actions give me the answer former
attorney general they are giving you two
sets of numbers right couldn't confirmed
Cova deaths
one number then unconfirmed possible
Cova deaths which is this vague category
maybe the person died of kovat but we're
not sure
so unconfirmed deaths which is a vague
category to define and hospitals are
doing the same thing by the way the
local governments have to submit
unconfirmed potential Cova deaths so
that's a little squishy by definition
and then I can I can see where there's a
vagueness in that category but they
submit these numbers under penalty of
perjury you violate you commit fraud
that is a criminal offence period so
they can be prosecuted criminally for
fraud on any of these reporting numbers
nursing home death nursing homes will be
like a fire through dry grass are you
concerned that there is this vast gap
between the reporting and also what is
the state been doing the past two months
to alleviate that or is it's been mainly
I'm sure you can't you can't you can't
confer you can't alleviate when they put
possible or probable or unconfirmed
cause of death that by definition you're
asking them a vague question and they're
giving you a vague answer so there's not
they could argue that's not fraud
because they did not know you're asking
them for cause of death
they're saying it's unconfirmed it's
possible it's probable but if they
misrepresented then you have a criminal
fraud case because it's one thing to say
you can figure out how to socially
distance in construction or say you can
figure out how to socially distance in a
manufacturing facility with adults and
you couldn't figure out social
distancing etc to say we're going to
figure out that plan and put it in place
in the next few weeks is virtually
impossible you know you can't you you
can't get just think of a school
facility right and again go back to this
room you have 30 kids in a classroom but
with social distancing you can only put
ten kids in a classroom okay then get
another three classrooms with another
three teachers I can't
cafeteria at lunch time I put 200 kids
in a cafeteria
well now you can only put 70 kids in the
cafeteria so have them eat in six shifts
you know and figure all this out and get
it done in a few weeks and make sure you
don't make a mistake because we're
talking about children and we're talking
about them getting infected and bringing
you either getting sick themselves or
bringing it home so the stakes are
higher
that you can't get to a whole phase two
of the reopening unless you have tool
for schools up and from a child
standpoint does that mean that we won't
get to a bulb base to in any area of the
state by the end of the academic year
well you during the academic year you
would need to get to a full phase to the
schools to be operational right you
can't say okay everybody in this thing
go back to work but the schools are
closed it'd be very hard for part of the
workforce to do that but you're at the
end of the school year anyway here in a
few weeks right and then you're in the
summer months and then the big question
is going to be September are you ready
to reopen the schools in September and
if you don't then you can argue you're
not going to be ready for a full
business opening if you're not opening
the schools in September I think that's
true first off I there's a huge this
time there's two protests going on
outside I know you can hear this time
because I can hear in here so I wouldn't
talk to them I wanted to know what was
going on one is reopen New York State
who you've already heard from the other
is citizen action New York and they are
asking you to cancel rent I asked the
organizer how how it would be funded and
she suggested that you tax billionaires
is is this idea feasible and what is
your response to that group of
protesters that are lined down
Washington yeah
you have protesters in front of this
building on a continuing basis you think
these are protesters you know there's
several dozen you come when we're doing
a controversial bill we have hundreds of
protesters all filling the entire
building it's like the building vibrates
with the chants and that's in some ways
great that's democracy people
opinion last week you asked about the
protesters who wanted everything open
the other day you asked about protesters
who wanted everything closed that's what
you get
one day it's everything open one day
it's everything closed my point is I get
their political opinion
I get the political spectrum I hear them
I understand what people say liberate
New York open everything up understand
why people say clothes everything you're
gonna kill my children you know so I get
the arguments and what I said is this is
not a political decision let's make a
decision on the facts etc I get the
people who say nobody should have to pay
rent I get that argument I get the
landlords who say in the building owners
who say if nobody pays rent I'm gonna
walk away from my building and then it's
going to be vacant and I'm not gonna pay
any bills because if they don't pay rent
I'm not paying bills and then you're
gonna have collapse of buildings what
what we're doing is no one can be
evicted for non-payment of rent between
now and June period period if a person
can't pay their rent because of the
situation they cannot be evicted that is
the law till June that law is in effect
till June and between now and June we'll
see what happens we'll figure it out
then we'll figure out what we need to do
in June last one report to the state
where people are coming from when
they're sick the covered their addresses
occupation we're now two months in
outbreak why didn't he require that
scenar when we could have tracked it
more I guess feasibly we have some of
the information but this is now going to
be an extraordinary when I get on the
phone with the hospitals they're going
to say this is a an extraordinary
reporting requirement right you had
emergency rooms that were overwhelmed
you had administrators who were
overwhelmed working 24 hours a day to
get this level of granular detail on
people who were walking in the door and
get it to us on a nightly basis this is
going to be a significant administrative
burden on them
are they essential workers there's no
such thing as an essential worker before
this how do they commute that's a
question that I don't think has ever
been asked of a patient before you know
if you are an essential worker where do
you work you know these are not
questions that the health care system
ever asks but since it's down to 1,000
new cases per day I'm going to say to
the hospitals I understand it's a burden
but it's 1,000 people statewide it's
only several hundred in downstate New
York I understand the burden the volume
is a little lower this is a little
granular it is more detailed than
anything you've ever done but it's
important for us to get it now so we can
come up with a more specific targeted
plant
Thank You summer camp decisions will
follow the regional decisions whatever
we do in that region will apply to the
summer
Apple and Google said this meant they
were teaming up to make it possible for
iPhones and Android phones to alert
their owners if they think they've been
in close proximity Apple and Google said
this meant they were teaming up to make
it possible for iPhones and Android
phones to alert their owners if they
think they've been in close proximity
with someone who later tested positive
for covert 19 it's called contact
tracing and for the two tech companies
it's become a bit of a controversial
endeavor both firms insist the privacy
is preserved and no personal information
ever leaves an individual's phone but
critics questioned the privacy concerns
and also whether the tech will even work
effectively at all here's how Apple and
Google say it should work let's say
there are two individual standing in
line at a grocery store we'll call them
Taylor and Meredith they've never met
before and they never speak while
they're in the store while they're in
there
Taylor's iPhone generates a string of
random letters and numbers called an
identifier Meredith's Android phone
generates one - the Bluetooth chips in
each of their phones can tell if they
come in close proximity with each other
without needing internet or GPS or Wi-Fi
or anything that could transfer personal
information it's a little bit like when
you buy a new pair of wireless
headphones and you turn your phone on
and you turn the headphones on and they
can at least see each other so Meredith
and Taylor's Bluetooth chips have
detected each other and exchanged their
random identify as a few minutes later
both devices generate brand new
identifies the owners leave the store
still having never spoken those identify
is stay on their phones for now so not
only are they nonsensical strings of
digits they're also only stored locally
but let's say a few days later Meredith
is positively tested for Co vid 19 she
downloads her local government's Public
Health Authority app and tells it about
the diagnosis in order to get the latest
medical advice what Apple and Google are
creating is a way for that app and
specifically only that app to also ask
Meredith's permission to give a contact
tracing server the random identifier
numbers that her phone's generated over
the past few days just those numbers
that's it so Meredith agrees the next
day Taylor's at home eating the food she
bought from the grocery store that
moment Taylor's phone detects that
there's an identifier on the server the
match
it's seen before in person a bit like
watching a televised lottery result
where the random numbers drawn on screen
match the ones in a person's hand on
their ticket hopefully the numbers mean
nothing in and of themselves of course
but because there's a match that means
something specific Taylor's phone has at
some point recently been near a person
who's tested positive for covert 19 if
Taylor also has the public health
authorities app her phone can tell the
app a match has occurred and then the
app can alert her and offer the latest
medical advice the app never sees the
random identify that the phone's matched
it just knows that a match has been
found and this is why Apple and Google
needed to work together
iOS and Android jointly run almost every
smartphone on the planet but their rival
systems and they speak completely
different languages critics say this
system can only be effective if enough
people opt in to use it and are widely
tested for the virus as well another
criticism is that in order to receive a
notification of the possible match users
need to download a specific public
health app likely one that their
government has endorsed well what if you
don't trust your government and what if
you don't trust Apple or Google they're
two of the biggest companies in the
world and already control huge amounts
of our personal data
critics ask do we want to give them more
responsibility Apple and Google's
partnering on contact tracing is their
answer to the question can the
smartphone revolution now be used to
help control a global pandemic the
answer may be yes but it'll be up to
each of us to choose whether we opt into
the contact tracing system in order to
find out the quick take in London
I'm a Langston